[Music]
thank you
um all right uh so my name's jesse
sadler i
am um a historian
um i teach at loyola marymount
university
um and so uh even though i am talking
about vectors today
uh what i normally do uh and just
quickly the slides are online and i'll
have a link at the end but
um what i normally do is i study history
i
am historian i'm interested in uh
merchant networks and merchant families
in uh
the 16th and 17th century and
uh i'm particularly interested in
inheritance
uh and what inheritance shows
about how people interact with each
other and how
families interacted with each other and
so that leads me to
doing math
specifically in terms of doing math
with non-decimal currencies so these are
currencies like here
this is flemish pounds but basically
currencies that are in pounds shillings
and
pence and this is a problem
uh because we don't learn how to do
non-decimal
arithmetic anymore and computers are
obviously based
on uh decimal arithmetic
and so you can't just plug these numbers
into a computer and do an
analysis on them it doesn't really work
that way
unfortunately so what exactly
is the problem space the problem space
is that you
with non-decimal currencies you have to
do
something called compound unit
arithmetic
right so you have to add up the separate
columns
and then divide by the base of that
column
and then you can get your answer so in
other words we have
a number of different problems here
we have three separate units that make
up one value
those units do not have decimal bases
so therefore we need to use this
compound unit arithmetic
and finally to make things even worse
the units can differ so
the normal sort of most used
units in historical currencies
is to have 20 shillings in a pound
and 12 pence in a shilling but they
could change
right so you guys didn't know you were
getting so much history
uh today jj in the keynote already
talked about history of corporations
this is what he's talking about i'll
have some
some stuff about corp well some ideas
about corporations um
so uh so there's a problem and you can't
just plug this
in um however
uh programming languages like r are very
flexible
and so you can um
use them to do this essentially
compound arithmetic um yourself
so what we want to do in a situation
like this
is we want to take these totals which
are just
added up right and then
normalize them do the compound um
unit arithmetic in order to get
um the answer that we want
and so you can make a what what i'm
calling here
a normalize function which basically
takes a vector of length three
the amount of units that we have and
then normalizes them
using a remainder
division essentially and then
brings them all together okay
so this is great we have a normalize
function we're ready to go
we've got something we can even
create an s3 class and
s3 classes who here has built their own
s3 class before all right a number of
you right s3 classes are great because
they're really easy to make right
i just built an s3 class right the um
key here is the structure part
right and so this is a class um
that has a value into it x and then it
has um i've called the class lsd
which is um uh the latin terminology for
pound shillings and pence
and then i've added a bases
attribute so that we can know what the
bases
of the shillings and pence units are
all right and so i can just do this and
i can
create something and it doesn't have a
nice printing
method or anything right now but i've
created an s3 class
okay so great i've created an s3 class
now i'm going to sit down i'm going to
figure out what am i going to
do with this what else do i need to do
well right now
i can only have one value at a time
so maybe i need to have multiple values
so i should use a list or something
and then i need to change the
normalization method okay no problem
all right so what else do i need to do
um okay
at this point it gets really confusing
because you have to
implement all these methods and it's not
really
clear how exactly you're going to do
them and what methods you have to
implement and why you need to do them
and
so on and so basically i went through
this
and i implemented some methods and some
i didn't
um and then i talked to hadley wickham
and he said no
what you should do is that you should
use
vectors and so um
vectors is a package that gives you
a path to implementing
all of those different methods
to actually creating your own s3 class
without having
to know everything there is to know
about
the different s3 classes so
um the goals of the vectors package
are fairly simple in some ways but
very deep it's about type stability and
size stability and hadley talked about
this at the last r studio conference
but i am going to focus on this last
aspect of building s3 classes
so what do you get by using this vectors
package well as i said before you get a
clear path
but you also get consistency with base r
it's just an s3 class and so there's no
reason why your users
would need to know that it's based on
vectors and then finally
it is integrated and continuing to be
integrated into the tidy verse
okay so what i want to do in this talk
and for the rest of the talk basically
is
talk about why you might want to create
your own s3 class through this example
of
non-decimal currencies why you should
use vectors and to point you to some
things of how you can do it
and i don't have enough time to go
through and uh do
all of a tutorial on this and show all
the different steps
and so what i've done is i've created a
a package that i'm calling deb vectors
which is a simplified version of the
package where i've done
more of this in debkeeper
and you see the urls there and what the
dev vectors packages
is it provides a tutorial of a
step-by-step
way to get through this and i will
go through some of these steps now
and so just as a aside the
image that you see there is a trademark
of an individual
who would use that so again more history
stuff
um okay so there's basically six
different steps to creating a
s3 class with vectors again i'm not
going to go through all these i'm going
to concentrate on the first
half the first three and i won't go into
the last three but i will talk about
them
uh you'll see that it how they are when
they're implemented
and if you're creating a class that's
based on double vectors you only have to
do four of these two of these steps you
get for free
and so just to give you an idea so dev
vectors is a package
and it's tested and it has everything
but
the way that the scripts are organized
is to
follow this and then within the scripts
uh they are uh there's a lot of
different comments on how to do these
things so i definitely recommend that
you
go and look at this that's on github and
you see the
url there okay so let's go through
some of these choices that i made with
deb keeper slash deb vectors and so just
as a reminder
right to go back to our problem space we
have to deal with these
issues of compound unit arithmetic of
representing a single value with three
different numbers
so um in designing this i thought about
different things so one
i didn't want to just decimalize
everything i wanted to maintain
the structure of the numbers
i wanted to keep track of the bases of
the shillings and pence because they
could
differ and i wanted to make sure
that if they if two values had
different bases that they couldn't be
combined in any
um but at the same time i did want to
create a decimalized class that i could
use as
a fallback and this would have the same
basic
attributes of a basis attribute that you
could
follow what the different bases of the
pounds and shillings are
but in addition it would have an
attribute
on the unit so it would be a decimalized
unit of
the pounds unit or the shillings unit
or the pence unit right and different
units can come together because they can
be the same currency
but there needs to be a way in which
that's done
um and so i'm calling these uh classes
deb lsd deb uh is short for double entry
bookkeeping which is where you find
uh all these different uh um
values and then deb decimal
so again i'm not going to go into this
but this just gives you an idea of
this are these are the steps within the
first
um uh major step of creating
the vector and so it's broken down
here and i'll just give you um
this uh slide which is a simplified
simplified version
of the creation of the class this
doesn't have any checks or anything
but you can see here the different
arguments
that we have on the left
the different vectors that can be put in
for
pound shillings and pence and then on
the right um
just the single one and then the
attributes of each class
um and then here we have the actual
creation
and so um with the deb lsd
when we want to keep these tripartite
structures
i'm going to use a record style vector
and so this
is essentially a list that
has equal vectors of equal length
and so um uh
that gives us a basis from which we can
have this different um structure
this tripartite structure um
on the right it's just essentially um
again a double vector um
so here we have now i'm skipping some
steps right but this
is what it looks like if we implement
our class
and so we can start here on
the left we have now a function where we
can create a class
and so we have different things that we
can add into
the pounds values the shillings values
the pence values
and here we're going to take our
standard
bases of 12 and 20. and
on the right is an equivalent
vector that is uh decimalized
and here we have uh the printing method
methods that i've chosen so again
these are things that you can create
so it has here i've chosen to include
the base attributes and the unit
attribute so it's very clear
and both work natively with tibble
[Music]
the record style vectors are not fully
integrated but
they're getting there so
the last thing i want to talk about here
that i have time to talk about
is the issue of casting
and coercion which is really at the
heart of
what is happening as you are
creating your vectors your classes and
want them to interact with other
different classes
so um the workflow's fairly sim simple
uh you have a
boilerplate that you're going to use on
each time and this is the same for
casting and coercion
where you define the method for the
class and then you give a default
then you do the methods within the class
and then the methods with any compatible
compatible classes that you decide to
choose
um so what um coercion and casting do
is they are kind of two sides of the
same coin
coercion looks for and determines
what the common type is
with this function vec p type 2
while casting does the actual
transformation
and so things like comparison between
classes
are made possible by implementing
both of these things so again i don't
have
a chance to go through all this but
coercion is really about design choices
there's not
necessarily that much code that goes
into something like this and so
in this instance with deb vectors i
decided to have
a double goes to a deb decimal
which would then go to a deb lsd so if
you had
these three types in a
combined function then you would get a
deb lsd
um casting is a little bit more
interesting because
this is where we have the programmatic
logic of the
actual transformation and um
one reason why i think that dev vectors
is a interesting uh
example of this is because i am
i have two different kinds of vectors
and so you have to think about how you
can combine them
in different ways and so here um
again the code is not necessarily super
easy to read
but this is taking a deb decimal
and then converting it to this
tripartite structure
and essentially what i'm doing is taking
simple if else statement what
is the unit and then from
that unit placing it where it should be
in a call to create a deb lsd
vector and then finally normalizing it
so that we get a normalized value so
that we've done
the compound unit arithmetic okay
so um how do we put it all together
so this is essentially the end point
here i'm just showing
that what you can get so we can combine
deb lsd deb decimal and
double and we get deb lsd we can compare
different types so 32
1555 pence is less
than 15 pounds and
again if you go on you can do arithmetic
including arithmetic
with different types so what i want to
say
is that you can create your own s3
vectors
uh you can extend the capabilities of r
to fix
your own fit your own needs and that
vectors
provides this clear developmental path
that
enables you to do this thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much jesse that was
fantastic we have a couple of questions
if you still want to sneak one in please
do
there's a question about whether you can
comment on your choice between
you mentioned explicitly s3 and vectors
did you consider our six classes and and
how did that factor in your into your
decision making um
so i looked at it a little bit but
mostly
i um was sort of interested in the
simplicity
of s3 and like i said i basically wrote
the entire package
with s3 based on lists and then
um i talked to hadley and then i had
like a month of work
to do so
the second question is once you had your
for
your data in vectors format what did you
have to do additionally to make it
compatible
with tideverse so um
like i said the especially if your um
vector is based on a double then it
pretty much
works right out of the um package
um right now with a
record style vectors there are
some things like mutate that don't quite
work but
i know that our studio is working on
that
but there you can just go back to base
r um things that work just fine
and hopefully soon
that will also get figured out and the
final question
what was the process what was your
original data format i mean how do you
go from paper record
into vectors yeah so um
it's it's fun thinking about the
questions of big data because
um i have to create all of my own data
um and uh it's also funny to think about
it in terms of reproducible data
oh don't change the data and it's like
well wait i created i can change it if i
want to
um but basically i take these numbers i
take these documents and i
input them by hand trying to figure out
what the numbers are
and do it in a spreadsheet
program and then export it to csv
and uh there is a
function in dev keeper but not in dev
vectors
but um that will take that and create uh
dev lsd uh
columns from those three different
columns
thank you very much thank you
you